well if anyone thought they were missing
out on seeing Wolverine truly go berserk
in the previous x-men films prisoners
makes up for that entirely prisoner
stars Hugh Jackman Jake Gyllenhaal Viola
Davis Terrence Howard and Melissa Leo
two families are coming together for
Thanksgiving dinner that's Hugh Jackman
and Maria Bello and Viola Davis and
Terrence Howard and suddenly after
dinner they're looking around and they
can't find their daughters anywhere it
turns out that they're both missing and
these two families along with Jake
Gyllenhaal who plays a detective in this
movie spend the rest of the film trying
to figure out what's going on where they
are who did it who's to blame and what
can they do about it prisoners is a very
deep and dark film that is filled with
lush cinematography immaculate editing
top-notch performances incredible
incredible dialogue and pretty much is
one of the best films I have seen all
year right from the beginning of this
movie I noticed that the editing was so
tense it's a film that takes its time
with its shots the cuts in the film are
not frequent which is a beautiful thing
to see the cinematography by Roger
Deakins who is my favorite
cinematographer is beautiful to behold
the kind of movie that opens very
quietly and you're like I really hope
the sound is working the sound is
working okay the sound is working so
many movies nowadays are like we had to
open with this big music and big opening
credit sequences and blow everyone away
and keep everyone all attentive and
everything to our film no the best way
to keep an audience's attention is
subtlety this is the kind of movie where
you lean forward in your seat and you
watch the screen you're thinking oh my
god I can't wait to hear every word
that's coming out of these characters
mouths because you're so riveted by the
screenplay and you really truly feel as
if you're watching real people in the
middle of a real situation because there
were times in this movie where I noticed
that I was actually gripping my fists
and I had to loosen up because this is
such a tense taut film that just kept me
on the edge of my seat throughout the
entire movie it's a film that from shot
the shot to shot is consistently
riveting and not just because it looks
incredible the performances in this
movie are absolutely terrific this is
probably the best performance I've ever
seen from mr. Hugh Jackman he is
absolutely magnificent in this movie
he's very stern you know he's very
protective of his family but he's not
like mr. nice guy I'm going to go out
and find the guy who did this in blah
blah blah know he is a messed up
individual
self and that's one of the great themes
about this movie is the villains and the
good guys are kind of blurry you know
everyone in the movie has stuff that's
wrong with them they're trying to work
through things that make them feel
pained about their past things they're
worried about in the future
and that's one of the things I loved
about this film were the various themes
that were weaved throughout the movie
about what the title prisoners really
means and about what all these
characters are dealing with currently
and the fact that even though the
central story of two abducted little
girls isn't terribly original
it's the way the story is told acted
filmed written that is so different and
original and that's one of the things
I've truly loved about this movie were
the themes behind it the things you
could take from it and like I said Hugh
Jackman is really good in the movie as
is Terrence Howard as the other father
it's the best I've seen him in years he
was so vulnerable he just you really
felt that through him this vulnerability
that was being portrayed through his
character that came out in the best way
in certain scenes and I absolutely
adored his performance Viola Davis Maria
Bello and Melissa Leo were all very good
in the movie as was Paul Dano as this
very troubled young man that I thought
he just did terrific I'm not always a
huge fan of his I think sometimes he
over acts a little bit too much but here
he was just right my favorite
performance in this movie though is
actually Jake Gyllenhaal as the police
officer who's investigating all of this
it really helps that he was in end of
watch last year and he went through all
that police training because he placed
such a convincing police officer but
it's not just the fact that he seemed
real and convincing in this movie I
thought that as a character he was so
interesting you really felt through him
the turmoil that he was dealing with as
he tries to solve this case and tries to
figure out where these girls are and he
did such an excellent job portraying
that that I really I just thought he was
amazing in this movie I mean I really do
think he's worth an Oscar nomination as
is Hugh Jackman everyone in this film
gave such a heightened level of drama to
their performances that continuously
from scene to scene I wasn't bored
despite the two-and-a-half hour runtime
it's the kind of movie where I actually
get excited when I noticed that two
characters are about to start talking
because I'm so interested in these
characters and what they're going to say
that I actually found myself like yes
what are the next words out of your
mouth please just I want to see this
scene I want to see these care it was
like in dark nights
when you got that scene where the Joker
and Batman were in the interrogation
room they're just sitting there talking
you know it's not some big science
fiction explosion extravaganza they're
just these two characters sitting there
talking and you're so riveted by it
there are so many scenes in this movie
like that where you just want to hear
what the next words out of these
characters mouths are going to be the
director of this movie Denis Villeneuve
I apologize if I said that incorrectly
but he absolutely knows when to go for a
wide shot and when to pull in the shots
are lovely they're composed so well
they're cut to perfection I mean this
movie's edited so well there's so many
times in the film where I kept thinking
oh they're going to do some stupid thing
with the editing here and by probably
like 10 minutes and I just realized this
film is going to look sound and feel
incredible for the rest of the runtime
and it did Roger Deakins man you are the
best cinematographer working today
another great thing about this movie is
from the first act to the second act to
the third act the movie flows and builds
perfectly it you just feel as if the
drama is continuously building in some
films you can identify like one scene as
that was the best scene in the movie
that scene was better than all the rest
this movie has a consistent building
tension where everything continues to
improve upon the last scene and it just
keeps getting better and better and I
could not take my eyes off of these
characters I adored prisoners it has
what I think is a perfect conclusion
it's one of the best dramas I've seen in
years this film absolutely deserves an
A+ guys listen to me I order you to go
see prisoners when it comes out I mean
it go to the theater and see this film I
have not been this serious about you
guys having to see a movie since Place
Beyond The Pines I mean it go see this
movie
it is incredible just go see it it's
really good so guys when you see the
film let me know you thought of it I'm
very interested in knowing and as always
thanks very much for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck minh heist